everybody what's going on welcome to the
seventh PI OpenGL tutorial video in this
video what we doing is I'm just going to
show you guys how you could add a ground
if you wanted so so like I was saying
before one of the ways that we can stop
a player from maybe going outside of the
bounds that we're creating cubes is by
having walls and one of those things
would be maybe a ground you could really
eliminate the idea of walls entirely and
just create a single plane on the ground
and eventually the plane has an edge and
if the player goes over the edge they
die and then you can take away the
ability to move up and down and then we
would put all the cubes on the ground
and then you would just avoid the cubes
still being 3d but you would just avoid
the cubes moving like left or right so
that's what I'm going to show you guys
now it's how might we do that so first
of all if you we can take this Y value
change and for now let's just say it's
zero and then we'll just comment out so
under the set vertices function so now
let's go ahead and save and run that
just just to see where we are so you
guys understand what we just did okay
so now all the cubes basically come up
right there now we're in theory kind of
below these cubes so that's not ideal so
instead of value change let's see was
worth zero let's say if we put these two
say a negative one let's try that
like I thought that's where we were
anyways okay so now they're like on
level with us right and so in theory we
could just add a ground and we could be
like okay we're avoiding these cubes
here okay so now let's go ahead and okay
there and now it's good let's let's
actually make a ground so how would we
how would we make you know this floor
well it sounds may be confusing but it's
really not so if we think about how did
we make the edge of
the cube well we specified vertex vertex
vertex vertex and we filled it in and
that was it that's all you have to do so
we can do the exact same thing for a
ground so for example we can come here
and we can say a ground this isn't
totally necessary but we'll basically
copy what we did for surfaces and edges
I mean my there we go
so what we could do is something like
ground and in fact we're doing two
ground surfaces actually we'll do ground
vertices and ground vertices will equal
a tuple and the tuple will be containing
a bunch of tuples and for example we
know that our X what our x and y well we
want to have X&Y be first of all the
ground we want it to be like slightly
under so we'll say Y value change minus
1 let's make it a zero for now anyway
or negative I'll have to test a few
things I'm having trouble having trouble
visualizing this but anyway you would
have negative 10 to 10 on the X right
the X should be negative 10 to 10 y
should not change at all and then Z
would be you know really far back in our
case max distance basically so so what
we could do is ground vertices a equals
and then we would say negative negative
10 negative 0.1 just slightly under I
think will work and then we don't want
it to just be like really short so are
really short rather so we want that
ground to start at some point for now
we'll just we'll have it start at the 20
and then let's just basically take this
copy come down here paste now now this
will be positive 10 right so these are
the starting points and then now really
deep we are going to have
again the exact same because this is the
ground so that's one two and then we got
three and four and this would be
negative ten and ten there and then
instead of twenty let's do negative 300
and then negative 300 okay then what we
need to do is we'll make a ground
function so we'll define round it'll be
empty parameters and then we'll just do
a simple GL begin if you don't recall
we use GL quads before to fill in and
then we'll just say X actually let's do
not like that so we're gonna say for
vertex in ground underscore vertices oh
my goodness I just want to spell
misspell vs. as much as possible for
vertex and ground vertices what do we
want to do let's we can color it first
so we'll do GL color three FV and then
in here you put the color tuple so let's
let's color it zero zero point five and
then zero point five okay and just take
note this is a tuple right it's a tuple
as the parameter next we'll do GL vertex
three FV and then the actual vertex okay
then then we're all done
GL end and that's it so now we've got
ground and then basically we can just
come down to our loop here and we'll
draw the ground let's go ahead and draw
the ground first so we don't have the
ground being drawn over the cubes in the
distance so we'll do ground and then we
draw the cubes so let's go ahead and run
that and see what happens okay so we
have our ground there we're on the
ground we see our cubes uh the ground
definitely just this is really messing
with me visually here but the ground
definitely you can see it does have
edges to it and stuff and we ran out of
cubes with the ground is a little I
think it was too high
so we could lower the
a little bit Stu negative will make this
negative one actually let's make it
negative one point one just do that
let's come down on these though
alright that's that's better so now that
appears like we have a ground we do have
an edge there and we can work with this
and so you can use this to make you know
the ground the walls and obviously we go
above and below but it's just a little
flat planes like right now we don't have
any rules that stop us from doing
anything but anyway you can imagine that
you could add some rules there so while
I don't intend to make this game and
have walls or grounds or anything like
that I did want to show like how you
could do it so if you're making like a
racing game you know you're gonna have a
street and you're gonna have the car on
the street and then you would you know
have it going off into the distance or
something and so that's how you could do
that so anyways that's it for this video
I just wanted to show real quick video
how you could add a ground if you wanted
I'm going to go ahead and not have a
ground them and just copy their comment
this out and then come down here and
comment this one out and then finally
come out the last one up at the top
wherever it is I can't even find oh hey
this is what we need to do yeah
that should give us back a good starting
position with random cubes right okay so
anyways that's it for this video the
next video will be continuing on and my
idea of having infinite range so sticks
you for that if you guys have any
questions or comments on this video
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching